la réforme doit avoir lieu dans group
captain médias à mon avis requiert que
les employés se mobilisent et la
communauté
écoutez c'est une opération qui perd
beaucoup d'argent un million par moore
pratiquement alors d'avoir un repreneur
financiers qui prendraient ça c'est donc
je vous exprime la difficulté au niveau
des médias publiera pour moi c'est une
solution que depuis le début je favorise
r ils ont seulement eu deux offres et
dans les deux offres même si
conditionnel c'est quand même le
meilleur
l'udc au de brand est professeur au
département de management de
l'université laval experts du modèle
coopératif mesure de brandebourg soir
bonsoir monsieur fillion alors le
ministre fatigué bundy qu'il favorise la
coopérative comme modèle d'affaires
comment ce projet là peut être viable en
fait premièrement ce qu'il faut faire
c'est pouvoir pour les gens qui nous
écoutent s'est distingué trois enjeux
you l'enjeu des fonds de pension yoland
jeu du modèle d'affaires et il range de
la forme juridique skill pour l'enjeu
des des fonds de pension évidemment faut
faire appel à des acteurs des actuaires
pour l'enjeu du delà du modèle la fable
de la stratégie on la connaît pas encore
dans cette stratégie on ne connaît pas
encore ce modèle d'affaires parce qu'il
n'a pas encore été dévoilé donc c'est
difficile de savoir exactement comment
ça va fonctionner par contre ce qu'on
sait c'est que l'option coopérative est
celle qui est choisi l'option
coopérative c'est à dire de créer une
coopérative ou des coopératives de
travail peut être viable dans la mesure
où le modèle d'affaires qui vont être
choisis par les coopératives est un
modèle qui est approprié au marché et
qui est approprié à l'industrie dans
lequel ces coopératives se trouve le
mode c'est pôle emploi les fonctions
d'un dans de toute façon le modèle
d'affaires doit fonctionner que ce soit
une coopérative ou une entreprise
incorporée exactement et s'y sent un peu
que les gens ont tendance à mélanger
c'est que le modèle d'affaires c'est la
stratégie c'est celle des questions par
exemple sont quelle plateforme
combien de jours semaines en vo publie
les journaux sont des questions qui sont
deux stratégies qui sont des cités au
sein de l'entreprise
le modèle d'associer le modèle
d'affaires la stratégie d'affaires et
son lycée
cette stratégie d'affaires là il ya
beaucoup d'enjeu il ya beaucoup de défis
qui font face à des entreprises dans le
secteur de l'information et l'a donc
modèle d'affaires sur les coopératives
avec des abonnés membres avec des
travailleurs membres avec des
compressions nécessaire la
transformation avec les technologies et
les crédits d'impôt l'état va jouer un
rôle important dans ce modèle d'affaires
tout à fait et pas uniquement l'état
pour que cela fonctionne il faut que les
coopératives qui vont être créées soit
bien né un ancrés dans leur dans leur
territoire ils soient accompagnés de
d'acteurs de gros acteurs d' acteurs de
l'écosystème à la fois des
accompagnateurs pour la transformation
en coopératif mais aussi des acteurs
financiers qui vont venir appuyer le
projet donc les coopératives seuls ne
peuvent réussir mais coopératif ont cet
avantage d'être dans un éco système
coopératif qui fait en sorte qu'on ne
les laisse pas tomber lorsqu'il ya des
grands défis devant elle alors le
champion de la coopérative
au québec c'est desjardins pourquoi
desjardins ne veut plus engagés dans
cette coopérative là où dans ce modèle
là en fait je ne connais pas je n'ai pas
de numéro de numéros de monsieur cormier
donc je peux pas vous dire pourquoi
desjardins spécifiquement le décès pas
s'engager
cela étant dit deux choses que je peux
dire premièrement si desjardins comme
institution ne veut pas s'engager ça ne
veut pas dire que les caisses
individuelles ne peuvent pas aider le
cas l'an il peut y avoir des caisses les
caisses de la région de québec pourrait
aider le soleil les caisses de la région
de sherbrooke pourrait aider la tribune
de sherbrooke
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose qu'il faut mentionner c'est que il
n'ya pas uniquement des jardins dans
l'écosystème même si d or est
effectivement un très gros joueurs il ya
d'autres joueurs qui ont montré un
intérêt et le fondaction est le fils
action et il ya d'autres joueurs qui
peuvent et qui peuvent appuyer les
coopératives et attendons de voir dans
les prochains mois si tout se passe
comme prévu et attendons de voir comment
les d'autres acteurs vont décider de
revenir ou peut-être des jardins vont
revenir sur sa décision je n'en sais
rien fondamentalement quelles sont les
armes
en otage d'opter aujourd'hui pour une
structure coopérative deux choses à dire
sur le sujet est premièrement il faut il
faut exprimer c'est quoi une coopérative
parce que mixa soit un modèle qui existe
depuis plus de 150 ans au québec il ya
encore et encore il est d'accord mais
connut une coopérative c'est quoi en
quelques mots ils savent à savoir
répondre à la 2 votre question de
coopérative c'est une entreprise qui est
dont les membres sont propriétaires dont
les membres sont décideurs un membre un
vote et dont les membres sont les
bénéficiaires
donc une entreprise coopérative à cette
caractéristique ces trois
caractéristiques là qui la distingue
fondamentalement d'une entreprise cotée
à la bourse
deuxièmement les coopératives ont comme
particularité d'être ancré dans leur
territoire et c'est là je crois qui est
un aspect important de choix qui est
fait de passer en coopératif c'est que
l'objectif c'est de faire en sorte que
les quotidiens vont vraiment maintenant
appartenir à la communauté
ils nous vont non seulement au service
de la communauté mais vont appartenir à
la communauté
et ça ça fait une différence c'est le
sentiment d'attachement peut être
l'autre clairement et de mobilisation
comme dit le ministre fait du québec
est-ce que des inconvénients à cette
formule
en fait il existe des coopératives dans
tous les secteurs d'activité au québec
des couvertures de travail dans tous les
secteurs d'activité d'activité au québec
est généralement elles fonctionnent bien
elles montrent un taux de pérennité plus
grand après 3 5 et 10 ans donc c'est un
modèle qui fonctionne évidemment les
enjeux qui qu'on peut avoir évidemment
ces deux sont des enjeux de de gestion
comme toute autre entreprise ou des
enjeux de gouvernance comme toute autre
entreprise souvent dans les coopératives
les décisions prennent peut-être un peu
plus de temps pour être prises mais une
fois qu'elles sont prises par l'ensemble
des membres
les membres vont dans la dans la
direction qui a été choisi ils sont
mobilisés pain pour la pour 7 pour aller
dans cette direction là monsieur den
brande c'est très intéressant très clair
vos explications merci beaucoup je
remercie